for
[Music]
on
come
she
fast
[Music]
behind
about what his body is doing when you go
like
this so
picture the back outward kazushi do you
see it this right here like this would
be where
Pok she is right
here so when he comes around like this
you you want
to let that body go
forward and ground on that other foot so
when you come around this way
B no no different than if you if you
were to do Co hole here Bo it's right
there right do that again when you're
doing K here it goes this way is where
it sends him back other leg it's a
little circle in other words so pay
attention to the little circle boom
there it is right
there so may look like I'm twisted him
up but he's running he's running into
that energy right there
boom and then I stay up with
him it's not me going
here that circle is very
important
you ground you ground there okay they
don't go so quick that you're just
reversing motion you have to
round round it
there in other words I'm projecting him
and then staying up with
him not going here and restling him down
bance right
[Music]
there
so you can make it big so you can see it
Bo
boom
okay
okay try just that point so I'm making
that
Circle and the other hand is just
waiting I'll do that side again okay
boom here comes that
Circle you see this hand not going to
reach over the top again
he's going to come backwards
remember is this
here there it
is that side
again you're you're doing this part
here and this hand is just
assisting
so still not kneeling
yet here's the
projection projection then I just hold
it
[Music]
okay still not healing okay if you just
want the guy to fall all that is enough
this this part's enough
okay but if you want to uh aim him
you're going to need right angle here
right angle there in the wrist
okay and right angle in the
elbow don't let it open don't let his
elbow open don't let his wrist open
right angle right angle and then
that I drive
down so all I did was for example
if his arm was going to travel straight
in Space by him
walking and I want to angle it over here
I'm just slowly making micro adjustments
to it okay you do it slowly over time
it's very natural so there's that
see cuz I don't have his wrist yet well
there it
is and then that will give you the go at
the end so still not kneeling just to
keep it easy but I'm here on the
wrist the projection doesn't change it's
still there as far as energetics go boom
right here I am
okay so he was already falling we
already know that he's already falling
there okay is just going to be able to
aim his fall when I aim his
fall his body is here his elbows on my
Center Line you see okay and as he's
going backwards I'm just gradually
lowering that do you get it got it okay
and I'm not going to crank this down I'm
going to turn around it so I'm always
just doing this C going to have to turn
with me so you can see
it Bo here I am see okay and I leave
that on my Center Line I'm doing two
things simultaneously it's staying on my
Center Line move with me camera staying
on my Center Line you
see okay and as it's staying on my
Center Line I am also turning the elbow
up
okay maybe you got to go over there
so when I get here I don't I just
turn there's no strength in it at
all it is
actually accentuated by the fact that
you got projected earlier on so pay
attention to that as I come here it
stays on my Center Line you
see and I just twist into the
knee his head's right underneath me now
I sit on his head
make his elbow stationary with whatever
you can and just do the goo and this is
reverse
Kimora
than